i want to do a quick refresher on
medians of triangles and also explore an
interesting property of them that will
be useful i think in future problems so
let me just draw
an arbitrary
and arbitrary triangle over here
now that's good enough
now a median of the triangle and we'll
see the triangle has three of them is
just a line that connects a vertex of
the triangle with the midpoint of the
opposite side so the opposite side's
midpoint looks right about there this
length is equal to that length and so
this is a median
close enough and of course we have three
vertices so we'll have three medians if
we start at this vertex we want to go to
the midpoint of the opposite side
it looks right about there so this blue
line right over here is another median
it's not a completely straight line but
i think you get the idea and we could
also do it from this point right over
here draw a line from this vertex to the
midpoint of the opposite side let's say
the midpoint of the opposite side is
there and we draw a line each of these i
could draw a straighter line than that
let me draw it
my
there well i think you get the idea
these are all medians of this triangle
and what's neat about medians is that
they all all three medians always
intersect in one point and that by
itself is a pretty neat property that
one point that they intersect in is
called the centroid
it's called the centroid and if this was
actually a physical triangle let's say
you made it out of iron and if you were
if you were to toss it well even before
you toss it the centroid would actually
be the center of mass so let's say that
this is an iron triangle let's say that
this right here is an iron triangle that
has its centroid right over here
then this irons triangle's center of
mass would be where the centroid is
assuming it has a uniform density and if
you were to throw that iron triangle it
would rotate it would rotate around this
point around
around a lot assuming that you it had
some rotational motion it would rotate
around that centroid or around the
center mass but anyway the point of this
video is not to focus on physics and
throwing iron triangles the point here
is i want to show you a neat property of
medians and the property is
is that the distance from if you pick
any median the distance from the
centroid to the midpoint of the opposite
side so this distance is going to be
half of this distance so this distance
right here is a then this distance right
here is 2a or another way to think about
it is this distance is two-thirds of the
length of the entire median and this
distance right here is one-third of the
length of the entire median and let's
just prove it for ourselves just so you
don't have to take things take things on
faith and to do that i'll draw an
arbitrary triangle i'll do a
two-dimensional triangle i'll do it in
three dimensions because at least in my
mind it makes the math it makes the math
a little bit easier in general whenever
you take a if whenever you have an
n-dimensional figure and you embed it in
n plus one dimensions it makes the math
a little bit easier
that the actual tetrahedron problem that
we did you could actually embed it in
four dimensions it would make the math
easier just much harder to visualize so
i didn't do it that way but let's just
have an arbitrary triangle and let's so
let's say it has a vertex there
a vertex there and a vertex there so i'm
not making any assumptions about the
triangle i'm not saying it's isosceles
or equilateral or anything it's just an
arbitrary triangle and so let's say it's
let's say it's coordinate let's say this
coordinate right over here is
i'll call this the x-axis so this is the
x-axis the y-axis and the z-axis i know
some of y'all are used to swapping these
two axes but it doesn't make a
difference so let's call this coordinate
right here a
0. so it's a along the x axis let's call
this coordinate
0 b 0 and let's call this coordinate up
here 0
0 0 c and if you connect the points
you're going to have a triangle
or just like that now the centroid of a
triangle especially in three dimensions
the centroid of a triangle is just going
to be the average of
the average of the coordinates of the
vertices or the coordinate of the
centroid the coordinate of the centroid
here is just going to be the average of
the coordinates of the vertices so this
coordinate right over here is going to
be so for the x coordinate we have zero
plus zero plus a
so we have three coordinates they add up
to a and we have to divide by three so
it's a over three
the y coordinate is going to be b plus
zero plus zero they add up to b but we
have 3 of them so the average is b over
3 and then same thing we do it for the z
coordinate the average is going to be c
is c over 3 and i'm not proving it to
you right here you could verify it for
yourself that it's going to be the
average that if you were to figure out
what this line is this line is and this
line is this centroid or the center of
mass of this triangle if it had some
mass is just the average of these
coordinates now what we want to do is
use this information let's just use this
coordinate right here and then compare
just using the distance formula let's
compare this distance
let's compare this distance up here
in orange
to this distance down here
down here in yellow and remember this
point right over here is the point this
is the median of this of this bottom
side right over here so the median of
that bottom side is just going to be the
average of these two points and so the x
coordinate 0 plus a over 2 is going to
be a over 2
b plus 0 over 2 is going to be b over 2
and then it has no z coordinates so it's
just going to be 0 0 plus 0 over 2 is 0.
so we know the coordinates for this
point that point and that point so we
can calculate the yellow distance and we
can calculate the orange distance
so let's calculate the orange distance
so that that is going to be equal to the
square root
the square root the orange distance is
going to be equal to the square root of
and we should take the difference of
each of these points squared so it's a
over 3 minus 0 squared so that's going
to be a squared over 9
plus b over 3 minus 0 squared so that's
b squared over 9
plus
c over c
c over 3 minus c which is negative two
thirds
that's negative two thirds and we want
to square that so we're going to have
positive
positive 4
over 9
c
squared did i do that right c over 3 so
1 3 minus 1 is negative 2 3 negative so
this is negative 2 3 c you square it
you're going to get 4 9 c squared so
that's the orange distance now let's
calculate and if we want to do it we can
actually we can express this let me
express it a little bit simpler than
this this is the same thing as the
square root of
a squared plus b squared plus four c
squared
over the square root of nine which is
just
equal to
that's just equal to three
now let's do the same thing with the
yellow distance
so it's going to be equal to the square
root
of
so if we have a over two minus a over
three so one half minus one third that's
the same thing as 3 6 minus 2 6 so it's
1 6 a
1 6 a squared is
a squared over 36
b over 2 minus b over 3 is b over 6 you
square it you get plus b squared over 36
and then finally if 0 minus c over 3
squared that's going to be c squared
over 9 but just so we get a common
denominator c squared over 9 is the same
thing as plus
4 c squared
over
36 and we can rewrite this as the square
root of a squared plus b squared plus
c squared
over
six
so you can see this distance right here
if you multiply this orange distance by
one half you're going to get so if you
multiply the orange distance by one half
or if you divide it by two so if you
multiply by one half you get the yellow
distance so this is always going to be
twice the distance as this because we
did this in the most general possible
way we assume nothing about this
triangle so remember that little
property that the centroid the
intersection of the medians if the
intersection happens two-thirds along
every medians two-thirds away from the
vertex or one-third away of the length
of the median away from the the midpoint
of the opposite side and we can use that
property in
well we'll probably use it in a bunch of
problems but anyway hopefully you found
that interesting